good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Tuesday do you
initialize the curds I initialize the
cards we are all ready to go don't worry
I run this studio when I'm down here
like this studio I understand my domain
herds have been initialized everything
has been cleared we're ready to go and
you walk in this studio you know you are
ready when I am here I know when I'm not
here you just have a checklist and like
we like now we're just so comfortable so
it doesn't matter but you know it's you
never want to be too safe I
have a checklist and I did it like I I
did it okay you weren't I now
uh when I do something by myself it is
an eye yes we didn't do it did you do
anything you didn't even know if the
memory cards were initialized I did do a
lot of things
yeah I gave you your sweatshirt I
dressed you I put it in the packages to
see what to wear I have been here for so
[__] long I have nothing else
to wear and I already was working with
you know my wardrobe here isn't great so
thank God for Bridget sending us these
bar sweatshirts because I'm wearing
yours today and it looks like I might
need to be wearing one each day of the
week I think she sent enough for us to
do so yeah and we can then like swap you
know it's like each permutation of like
what colors will each wear I think we
have like 10 options total per mutations
per mutations
um so it's Tuesday
which doesn't mean anything that's
really interesting that it's Tuesday it
doesn't mean anything no it means that
we're in it though you know we've
officially entered the week it's true
we're no longer like shy like dipping
our toes in and like wanting to go
backwards like we're foraging ahead in
this new week we're kind of like
foragers Yeah in our forest green
sweater yeah yeah it's nice yeah I think
it's good it's been a great week so far
with my girl turd we had such a fun day
yesterday working eating playing that is
exactly what we did yeah we worked we
ate and we played so [__] hard hiring
at seven o'clock he was like I gotta go
to bed guys yeah he's too much he wiped
me out too much and I think I'm looking
forward to another day of such things
today I'm looking forward to another day
of working of playing and definitely a
beating for sure we haven't made a plan
for the third part and I don't like when
we don't have a plan well I've kind of
just been you know really focusing all
my energy on planning a really gorgeous
episode for Thursday
yes you guys don't know it but
Thursday's episode is kind of like an
enormous Milestone here at the toast it
is going to be our 1
episode four digits four digits 1
000 episodes and I do believe we are
entering a very premium category of
podcasters I can't even think of course
Joe Rogan has over a thousand he's up to
like 1500 or something I'm sure the
daily has but like I don't really
include them if your podcast is owned
and like by like a major Media company I
don't consider you a podcaster you know
what I mean yeah you hear someone with a
job you're just like a media company
like I'm talking about independent
podcasters I feel like maybe Heather
McDonald has reached a thousand because
she's been doing this long before anyone
yes and there was someone else because
we've had this conversation once before
and like someone wrote in the comments
of another podcast I was like oh yeah
they definitely have a thousand episodes
but it's a very small Club I would say
it can't be more than 10
podcasts that are in the top 200 of
podcasts that have a thousand yeah you
could have a thousand but like no one
listens yeah yeah so it's kind of like a
big week it is a really big week we've
kind of been creeping towards this
Milestone always being excited for it
always hoping that we would be together
for it and we didn't even plan this so
it's so Kismet but shared they share
that we're going to be together on
Thursday for our 1 000th episode and
I it will probably be an episode just
like any other an amazing one an amazing
one we're so excited and feeling so
hashtag proud
um but like maybe we should just take
the episode off like maybe it's like
okay we've done 1000 episodes like
let's stop talking let's take a day off
yeah yeah but then but then we wouldn't
have a thousand yeah in the next day and
we just like we would never do it
because we keep thinking we deserve this
day off right so I don't we don't really
have anything planned yet but just know
it's going to be a really special
episode if you have any ideas like for
what we should do let me know because
I'm kind of like drawing a blank yeah
I'm sure people come up with good ideas
they probably all include like watching
our first episode back which like I know
logistically like well one I could never
one no no two like logistically how
would that work like you're gonna bring
a TV in here we're gonna watch it no I
okay well this is our thousandth episode
of the toast yeah we did a year of our
show before we rebranded from the breath
um I would be happier to watch the first
episode of the breath and then I would
be watch the first episode of the toast
because I could never well I I literally
could never watch the first episode of
the toast no I couldn't but we could do
like a a roulette where we just like
pick one Random episode like 369 right
right and we watch that yeah something
like that but again statistically it's a
kind of a nightmare we should pick 213
why
because that's Harry's birthday take
longer to remember your son's birthday
yeah you kind of like kind of said like
that was kind of like an entrapment
situation like you knew and you were
just like trying to see get me okay but
like if anybody ever said we should do 7
10 I'd be like oh that's my birthday you
know like I wasn't thinking in terms of
birthday like I would say what was 700
like what year was that like what 7 10.
okay it's fine I was just like really
thinking really practically yeah well I
think we should do 213. okay 2 13 it is
for patreon because like we could use
the TV out there it won't be in the
studio we could bring our camera yeah we
could give it a shot we'll give it a
shot but in the meantime just keep in
mind this big milestone coming up it's
kind of a big week for your girls and I
think more importantly than doing like a
fun segment or you know something crazy
it's just to take stock yeah where
we came from
where we're going and just like be a
little proud of ourselves we really
never take the time to like stop and
look around there and be like wow we did
that yeah so maybe the Thursday episode
will just be a silent episode of a
staring a sitting and reflecting and
then and asking you to reflect with us
you know on on who you've become since
you've started listening to the toast
how long have you been listening to the
toes how is your life change it'll be a
lot of us looking forward
and looking back
but then looking forward again
towards the future
and you know what the future is it's
bright and toast what's that Hebrew
phrase odd
120. oh we passed 120. no but like it's
120 years oh like when you wish someone
a birthday you're like happy birthday
odd 120 like may you live till 120. okay
maybe toast till 120 yeah
1200.
yeah we'll figure out the verbiage yeah
we'll figure out the official official
slogan but we just wanted to get you
guys excited in the lead up to 1000 and
and hear from you what you would like to
see from us yeah big day our 1000th
episode yeah big day
make that huge so other than that you
know enormous life-changing Milestone we
just got a gorgeous show today you know
a couple stories no tomorrow's your
toaster so just like a regular you know
good old-fashioned episode of the toast
Jackson Claude no brass no Strat oh no
Bryce no strikes those boys did not want
to work today I could relate yeah you
know yeah they were like you guys have
to go but we don't we don't yeah we'll
just wait for you to put kibble on the
table and we won't and we showed
they said that they did
so you want to Dive Right In yeah I mean
I don't really have anything else to
like catch people up on do you no
because I'm caught up with you we
haven't been watching television we've
been reading our books it's a couple of
studious girlies you started a new book
yeah it did it was like you know a spicy
wreck I think maybe I got it from the
redheads book or from snatchler redheads
group sorry okay um it's called
scandalized it's fine you don't need to
read it but it's fine I'm reading the
marriage portrait which Dana recommended
because it's historical fiction it's
about the medicis and she really liked
it and she doesn't read that genre so
she's like these are your people like
you should read this book it was really
good and like I cannot get into it
um I will Forge ahead but it's just
dance and dance
um
so that's really it Jay I mean yesterday
actually kind of was like a big
milestone because we you know sat down
in bed with Harry and we turned on the
toast for him and he wasn't interested
not the slightest yeah and then we
turned on his rage and he was like
dazzled you know Yeah Yeah by her it was
it was it was a tough loss I'm not gonna
lie maybe we need to punch and I feel
like this camera's a little too far away
he might like a remote episode yeah I
just felt like you know audio wise he
would connect with it immediately
because you know in utero you did nine
months of episodes like I thought he
would immediately kind of recognize it
yeah I feel like he's a little jaded
because he gets it all the time now like
he could have toast on demand whenever
he wants yeah and he was like why would
I sit and watch this when I'm literally
sitting in between you two [__] no
and he was also just like shut the [__]
up and put on this Rage which yeah is
fair it is like we're not necessarily
like teaching him anything you know
that's a lie
no we're not teaching him to clap or but
he was literally looking at the TV and
then he was looking at you to his right
yeah and me to his left and he literally
if he could speak he would say you guys
are obsessed with yourself yeah no he'd
be like the [__] like girls get a grip
that's what he's gonna say girls like
it's not that good no so true but he
would be wrong it is that good yeah it
is but is it like
good that we have to watch like that
episode that day like with him yes when
he probably can hear it downstairs I
mean yesterday with the Grammys recap
like it was that's true you know there's
a lot of discourse in our comment
section about you know who deserved
album is really kind of like the Beyonce
versus the Harry found it was crazy how
like those fandoms like feel so certain
like no it what Beyonce was the album of
the year like it just was and then Harry
people are like Harry's album was and I
guess it's like good to see and there's
really no consensus because art is
subjective but I had no idea that it was
that intense contentious between the two
groups yeah
so
so you know get a life
no I'm kidding I'm kidding I understand
the passion but trust me if Kelly was up
for album of the year like I'd be in the
comments like it was Kelly's here it was
the year of Kelly speaking of Kelly did
you see her collab with pink I did but I
didn't like I've seen that it exists but
I haven't digested it yet they sat down
and sang a few songs not just one like
they did this really beautiful like
acoustic Harmony version of some Pink
songs it was really good pink you know
stop by the Kelly Clarkson show and
Kelly you know as she does put her to
work
I'd hurt away okay I need to like sit
down and enjoy it I don't want to see
like a 10 second clip because he's been
killing me I've seen that it exists and
I also was listening to like you know
some cool kids playlist on Spotify this
morning and there was a new pink song in
there have you heard it how does it go
it's called trust fall I couldn't I only
heard it once I couldn't tell you how it
goes but it's so gorgeous that's so pink
and I was listening to it like right
after flowers which like is one of my
least like best songs ever and like is
getting so much hype and Fanfare and
it's like pink puts out fire flame songs
every time she puts out a song it's like
she doesn't even get a fraction of the
height because you wanna know why like
pink is we take her for granted yeah but
pink is just kind of cemented herself
like as an icon like she doesn't need
these elaborate viral promotional things
like she just has a huge audience and
her songs like do well and I think she's
just like happy and fulfilled with that
like she doesn't need to be number one
all the time you know what I mean she
does it for the art but it's like I'm
not saying she should be doing more I'm
saying as fans like we should be like
propping up the best song I know and
it's like she's always giving us the
best song and then someone gives us like
a pretty good song and we're like yeah
no pink is out here just like
consistently doing the most and we're
just taking it for granted that's what
that's like what I said two minutes ago
that we take her for granted no and
that's me agreeing with you okay I
thought it was that you coming at it as
if it were a new thought
once again our agreements have left us
speechless yeah
and feeling targeted
so perhaps that would be a good time to
get into some divisive stories that we
can Jackie says she's a hot take coming
out at for us I do have a hot take I'm
really excited because it's a historical
hot take too and it's relevant in
present day it's for everyone all right
well let's do it then without further
ado
here are the past size stories that you
need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
rocket money
try it free for 30 days is enough time
to try and completely forget about about
a subscription or a service before you
know it you're paying for a subscription
that you don't use for months on end
with rocket money you can change that
within a few quick Taps so rocket money
which is formerly known as known as true
bill is a personal finance app that
finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place over 80 percent of people have
subscriptions that they forgot about
like that streaming service you bought
just to watch one new show on or that
free trial that you never actually used
rocket money will click quickly and
easily identify your subscriptions for
you so you can stop paying for the ones
that you don't want simply find the
subscription that you don't want press
cancel and Rocket money will cancel it
for you there's no long hold times with
customer service no tedious emailing
back and forth rocket money makes
canceling subscriptions as easy as the
click of a button over 3 million people
have used rocket money saving the
average person up to two up to 720 a
year so true by the way like I get like
things that keep me up at night were
like all the things that I had put down
my credit card for for a free trial and
forgotten about and Rocket money just
like did that for me not only for me but
like I have so I have different bank
accounts like for personal for work and
I'm always putting like random things on
the business rocket money was just out
here like yeah rocket money was just out
here clearing my conscience so stop
throwing your money away cancel your
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com toast that's
rocketmoney.com toast rocketmoney.com
t-o-a-s-t today's episode is also
brought to you by Thrive Market our
go-to for all of our grocery and
household essentials and the convenience
of getting it all quickly shipped to our
doorstep is a huge Time Saver we have
gotten so many good deliveries while
I've been here from Thrive Market this
house runs on Thrive Market because you
guys you know I'm in my clean era one so
one it's like an organic grocery
shopping online like there couldn't be
anything for me it's like digital
grocery shopping organic like baby easy
to search like based on what you want so
easy to search they have like all the
Best Brands all the best snacks baby
food and then I also try new things they
also like Thrive Market brand and stuff
so like I have their dates that they're
so good and I kept trying to convince
Kayla that they were chocolate yeah but
it's also a really good place to
discover new brands because it sounds
you're typical they're not like other
brands no and love and like it's great
because everything is like vetted good
for you organic
it has the Thrive Market stamp of
approval right which means everything
you don't have to go around checking the
backs of the labels as a Thrive Market
member we save money on every single
order on on average we are saving 30
percent each time so we literally got a
box two days ago uh Zach weinrib was so
excited he was like can I open it we're
like um no on top of the massive savings
on each order Thrive Market has deals
and a deal page that changes daily so it
gives us cash back on so many Brands and
they have a price match guarantee so
they save us money but they also save
time love the filters on their website
or their app they have over 70 filters
so whether you're looking for certified
gluten-free snacks non-toxic cleaning
Essentials
um you can curate your own shopping
experience with the click of a button so
whatever your dietary restrictions are
like we have a lot
um it's so easy you don't have to sit
through products that you cannot
purchase because that filtering system
is like kind of revolutionary also they
have Frozen Foods so they'll send you a
frozen food box like I got frozen pizzas
I love we love this one brand that are
like the best pizzas ever
um some frozen mac and cheese like meals
for the week and they come fresh frozen
join Thrive market today and get 30 off
your order plus a free 60 gift that's
thrivemarket.com the toast for 30 off
your first order plus a free 60 gift
t-h-r-i-v-e-market.com the toast
thrivemarket.com the toast Frozen Foods
is so Marjorie post real ones no
all right do you want to know why that's
so Mercury post okay okay so she like
took over Post Cereal I know her dad
invented and then she acquired a brand
called bird's eye oh and frozen foods
and she was the first one to like make a
bet on frozen foods that people would
want them in their home and get an ice
box and then eventually a freezer and it
was like the Best Buy interesting I have
birthday in my freezer I love her yeah
they're like in millions of grocery
stores yeah so like she really is like
she did the Pioneer she did that cool
that's cool Pioneer Frozen Foods well
except the guy that she bought bird's
eye from like right he was really the
finder but like she took a chance on an
unknown Frozen Foods Fisher
it's really cool okay just move on like
come on I just I
first Story drama in Montana oh
Kevin Costner's Yellowstone work dispute
Sparks cancellation Buzz have you seen
this I I did but I just kind of brushed
it off I know I'm like in denial but
here is what we know okay Paramount
Network Paramount Global and series
co-creator and showrunner Taylor
Sheridan could be ending the popular
Western in its current form sources told
deadline on Monday but are trying to
extend the franchise with a new show
starring Matthew McConaughey okay I
don't believe all of that the show's
potential shuttering comes insiders
allegedly claimed as the show's current
Car Star Kevin Costner is reportedly
having disagreements over shooting
schedules the friction is allegedly
causing morale issues with fellow actors
on the show in a statement to the post a
Paramount networks postperson shot down
the rumor and attempted to put fans
Minds at ease saying we have no news to
report Kevin Costner is a big part of
Yellowstone and we hope that's the case
for a long time to come yeah thanks to
the brilliant mind of Taylor Sheridan we
are always working on franchise
expansions of this incredible world he
has built Matthew McConaughey is a
phenomenal Talent with whom we'd love to
partner so they definitely have
something brewing with Matthew
McConaughey and I don't think that
necessarily has anything to do with the
other story yeah the other story though
so sources claim that he originally
Kevin Costner allotted himself 65 days
to shoot the first part of the series is
current Fifth Season which we saw and he
only ended up wanting to shoot for 50
days now as the cast is shooting the
second half of the episodes Kevin
Costner reportedly only wants to spend
one week filming which is causing an
alleged Rift okay I don't know why I've
like always kind of envisioned Kevin
Costner it's like a real you know down
home All-American like humble modest
like not difficult person so I'm having
a hard time putting him in that box but
it does sound like he's literally being
difficult like I understand like not
wanting to work like respect it
um however like you just won the Emmy
you're on the biggest show on television
Golden Globe sorry you're on the biggest
show on television like I would think he
would be even more excited than ever I
know about this show I so I feel a
couple ways about it like on the one
hand where there's smoke there's fire
and we have to acknowledge the smoke and
that like because statement kind of
corroborates that Kevin is part of this
Furious comments yeah like he shaved 15
days off his work schedule I'm sorry you
can't like film the second half of a
show in one in a week like you're gonna
have to do more on the other hand I kind
of feel like these like deadline and
these like Media Insiders like want to
take down Yellowstone yeah because it's
so popular it's an outlier yeah it's
like it it shouldn't be this big right
and I feel like they kind of love
drumming up the drama within it and I
think Matthew McConaughey would actually
be really good for a spin-off me too but
if he in some way shape or former places
Kevin Costner I don't know if the fans
are gonna go for that no also I just
they'd be better off ending the show
because like when there's like a lack of
continuity it's just it's confusing or
they'd be better off like killing Jon
because everybody wants to kill John all
the time and at some point like he will
have to die right and then like we see
how the kids like we've always been
preparing for the Next Generation so
like we could see how that was the part
of the show like you really can't and
there's really not uh
absolute replacement unless it's rip no
like rip and Beth yeah
and they can make other characters more
likable like Casey this is he's getting
better this is so um like weird to me
because like
to me you're right like Yellowstone is
outlier show it's like was never
supposed to be successful like it became
the number one show plus it was the
number one show on television and like
to me they're perfect you know yeah
they're so happy like they can't believe
all they're the best job in the world
and it's like Kevin Costner took on this
job when it was an unknown nothing show
filled with like a cast of people I've
never seen before unknowns and now that
it's the biggest show in the world he
like couldn't be a bigger star like now
is the time when you want to turn your
back like that's a little maybe the
Golden Globe is like getting to his head
you think or it's like it's become too
mainstream I've got to go maybe he's
like more like an indie artist yeah and
he's like were too big I don't know I
I'm feeling really disappointed if any
and you know what I feel like this is
meant to like so Discord amongst the
fans you know and I feel like I would
agree Yellowstone family have to stay
strong I would agree if it weren't for
that statement from Paramount like they
just corroborated the whole story yeah
they said we hope he's a part of it and
on the other hand they like wouldn't you
know talk [__] about Matthew McConaughey
because they are talking to him in
contracts right so I'm feeling Beyond
disheartened like I was ready to brush
this whole thing off until he read the
statement yeah there's something there
the Brethren have snuck into the studio
there's something there there's
something there that wasn't there before
what's it from Beauty and the Beast
there must be something there that
wasn't there before
so
so that was like not great news to start
the day no that's [__] horrendous I
saw it read the headline and just like
brush it off I'm like oh everyone's
coming for Yellowstone classic jealous
wenches yeah turns out turns out maybe
they're not so jealous those wenches no
they're still jealous but maybe like
they're not lying they're not lying
maybe they're not lying wenches
so we'll see
let's see how the second half of season
five goes and like how so you're saying
they haven't even filmed it yet they're
filming it okay where's Kevin
who knows it's literally Home Alone
where's Kevin passes to Kevin
who knows but he also listed his 168 60
years Aspen Ranch for rent yeah so like
maybe he's just kind of like done
disposing of his material items yeah
that ranch I I looked at I looked into
it
um for 36 000 a night I guess he's gonna
get that material item it was just like
a little out of my price range um which
was upsetting because it was like kind
of the perfect house for me you ever see
a house it's like so you whether it's on
Zillow or like a celebrity listen it's
pretty gorgeous yeah oh and imagine the
Brethren yeah it's like the sound of
music yeah you ever just see a house
that's like really kind of designed for
you and then you find out it's just like
Millions out of your price range it's I
just hate when that happens yeah oh in
this article about the house it said
rumor surface on Friday as to whether
season five of The highly popular series
would be his last no there's something
going on with Kevin and like what are
you doing Kevin even though I will say
there is a time to end a show and I
don't know if it's the yeah if
Yellowstone's time but like it really
isn't like amazing anymore no I'm loving
it more than ever because it's just
Comfort yes no now it's like a soap
opera that you tune into every week it's
a western soap opera but it's not like
this drama-filled like best show on TV
like I'm surprised that like he won the
Golden Globe this season they should
have won it like three seasons ago you
know yeah and I'm not saying it's its
time yet but a time does come and I
respect a an actor and an artist knowing
when the time is up and not just letting
a show go on for decades
um but it's not the time yeah it's
getting close but it's not the time no
but and he could go but I think the show
should stay and I think it really should
turn into like what's next second gen
second gen well actually it's like 8th
gen next gen next gen Jen Jen bip yeah
and it's and it's ripping Beth yeah Jen
ref even though it will pass too
what's Casey's boy's name annoying Tate
take your opacity to the annoying kid
who's going through puberty he's like
you know it's always tough watching a
show that goes on for a long time when
there's a young boy on it because he
eventually goes through that phase bran
where they've got like a hairy upper lip
and their voice cracks and they're just
they're not they're not cute anymore
yeah I know every kid especially a boy
like goes through like a really weird
ugly phase
and it's Universal it's not you know
it's everyone yeah it's tough to watch
it really is bran
and Tate's going through it um yeah damn
but um yeah I guess because Beth can't
have children biologically but they got
that kid that run away they do that many
rip you never know like Miracles have
happened yeah
she had a hysterectomy like I don't
think that's that's not like a miracle
that's just like impossible yeah
I don't know
like maybe they could come to love that
kid as their own yeah but like
I don't know if if that would work for
them to pass it down it's like not why
yeah no and it's not like they're gonna
give it to Jamie's kid actually but
Jamie's not even right Jamie's not even
Jamie's not even he should leave it to
the Strother and they would love it they
would
clean that [__] up like it would run it
like a and they would enjoy it you know
and they would get like the finances
right their business spend these
Brethren yeah they are what makes his
brother they knew they had to come to
work even though they didn't want to
even though they're sleeping on the job
do you think they were like talking to
each other out there like should we go
in I know it's like moms are gonna be
mad at us but like they're like
listening out there like the show's not
that good yet maybe they need us look at
them both they came in together like
yeah hey we're here to help yeah like
hey we heard the show sounds like you
could use our help
I love you boys mom's Angels I'm so
devastated about this like I know one
thing about Yellowstone we could count
them on count on them for it's like no
no off the scenes No Hollywood drama no
ego Diva yeah totally but looks like
there's just like every other show and I
also like want to keep
my head like a level head about this
because I also know they're trying to
come for Yellowstone to come for
Yellowstone so true and they're trying
to make it look like it's Yellowstone
coming for itself but like it's deadline
jealous wenches jealous you can never
have this audience that's so big
are you ready for our next story some
more drama yeah quavo and officers fight
backstage at the Grammys 2023 over the
tribute to takeoff
so cuevo and offset got into a brawl so
intense backstage during Sunday night's
2023 Grammys that they had to be pulled
apart according to a new report the two
performers apparently feuded over the
musical tribute to take off the late
rapper who served as one-third of their
group Migos
sources at the award show told the
outlet that just before cuevo took the
stage to perform his song without you
during the in memoriam segment he and
offset got into a physical fight over
the fact that quavo allegedly refused to
allow offset to participate in the
tribute despite the Grammys requesting
it cuevo even went so far as to block
offset from joining him on stage which
led to fisticuffs Reps for the Grammys
and books fisticuffs like uh is that a
phrase that's a word like you know
fighting rubber all yeah okay Reps for
the Grammys and both rappers didn't
immediately return uh requests for
comment
um but offset tweeted something later
and then there's also a video of cardi
bailing at both of them backstage Queen
on her Queen [__] right like for me the
cuevo and offset fighting like isn't
that juicy to me like you know they're
in a band they lost someone grief like
it happens yeah and apparently uh prior
to takeoff's murder last fall cuevo and
takeoff had been extremely close but
offset had been on the outs from the
group but they're also all family
takeoff was quite nephew and offset is
cuevo's cousin okay so they're a family
so again like makes the brawl less
explosive like families fight especially
during dark times but for me like what I
loved about this was cardi B like
literally getting in their faces like
these two big round men and telling them
to like literally stop but she was being
such like a mom yeah if you listen and
talk about Entertainment Tonight being
at the right place the right time like
they just have to have their camera
backstage and they literally caught the
whole thing I'm like and it wasn't it
wasn't um she wasn't yelling at them it
wasn't like fighting it was just like
almost like reprimandingly stop like
you're both wrong and you guys need to
stop it yeah she said you're both wrong
it was so like it was so iconic it was
iconic like I love she doesn't care
we're backstage at the Grammys but you
know you need to be putting your place
and I'm gonna be the one to do it like I
literally I'm sure there were tons of
people around and like I feel like
another celebrity would be like shot at
pretend like everything's okay like it's
okay honey yeah no like 100 and then we
she walked past the Entertainment
Tonight Like interview station and they
were like we heard you you know putting
people you were playing something over
and she was like no I was just fixing my
dress just smoothing my outfit over like
she was just being a queen she was being
a queen it's honestly the best video
it's sad to hear that they were fighting
like about this tribute and that you
know things are well it's weird that
quavo like you know
try to cut out offset yeah but like
in one it's quavo's song two well like
it's not even cuevo song they sang well
it's two songs it's been a long day but
can you sing another song yes I know but
yeah but I'm not defending quavo but I'm
just saying like you never know cuevos
POV of course from our side it's like
you're all cut family and you're all
members of Migos you should all yeah but
by the way it was quavo's song Because
quavo wouldn't let anyone else be a part
of the tribute but maybe like he wrote
the song on his own like I'm sure let me
look up the song and see if it can just
says they could have found something for
offset to do if it's really but he
didn't want to right why Why
without you bye
quaver
s
quite
says cuevios is that his like artist's
name on his own Perhaps Perhaps yeah
that probably makes sense
yeah
he has one song without you okay so it's
his song and like he didn't want the
other guy in it like yeah but like they
chose that song because he blocked out
offset it seems to be a song that he
wrote about takeoff I'm just saying like
they were all family they were all in a
band and like they all deserve to to
grieve yeah that's true and I just can't
explain how like with cardi B around
like I'm just not worried I know they'll
figure it out yeah it's a hard time you
lose someone at a young age and it's
like hard to like you lose perspective
yeah like you do crazy [__] like blaming
the wrong people and I understand me too
I think they're gonna be okay as long as
Carter is putting them in their place
like she's so like really like
channeling her mom energy no it was
honestly like I'm sure she was going
through stuff backstage like she looked
she was the best dressed at the awards
like she it wasn't even nominated for
anything but it was Cardi's night no now
we know she was like holding it down the
fort backstage like Queen doing Queen
[__] yeah respect
anyways I hope they can work it out me
too it's so tough when families you know
start fighting but they'll find their
way back to each other
yeah are you ready for our next story
twitters and you people everywhere are
slamming Leonardo DiCaprio over his
romance with a 19 year old um so
Leonardo DiCaprio who is 48 is now
dating a 19 year old model A Den polani
he was first pictured with her at um a
release party for uh EP and
they were you know seated next to each
other at some event and whatnot
so disgusting I mean she's so gorgeous
she's 19. to put things into perspective
someone said she's so young her high
school education was interrupted by
coven yeah no this is really sick and I
guess I didn't even really put together
how
Leo's almost 50. I've just been
considering him like a man in his 40s
like now he's 15. you know this is
really really crazy because it used to
be like 25 hahaha like okay so he's
dating someone 23 but like 19 is right
on the border of legality is so young
he's really disgusting
yeah like this is gross yeah like why
can't you stomach the idea of being
someone being with someone who is like
30 emotionally mature yeah no and it's
like
it's so consistent it's clearly a
pattern but like I can't even remember
the last time he dated someone
age-appropriate
yeah probably when he was that age that
he likes right
so gross like I and he has no shame like
you know the whole world is like talking
about you and like we're like you're you
know teetering on the edge and like you
go lower yeah
but she's really beautiful no I know and
she's seen the pics yeah and she's like
an Israeli Queen yeah and you know it is
worth mentioning and this is a joke so
don't come for me but like you know
there is a draft in Israel for for men
but so I don't know if she went to the
Army but if she did you know you grow up
really fast in Israel you're like
constantly under attack you know people
hate you so she's 19. I would say she
probably has a maturity of a 25 year old
yeah still disgusting still not okay but
just worth mentioning worth mentioning
she's probably mature for her age which
is a young age yeah no Leonardo DiCaprio
is really disgusting and it's like
it's become such a joke I feel like when
he goes to award shows like Ricky
Gervais are always making a thing of it
and now it's just something we laugh at
but it's deeply and inherently
problematic and disgusting yeah so we're
like laughing at it but let's talk about
it you know yeah let's talk about it
let's talk about it also Leo related not
a story though James Cameron like
finally admitted that the door on the
Titanic that Rose floated floated on
could have held both of them right he
held like a science experiment it was a
reenactment with stunt doubles and he
conceded that they could have both been
on the door which is what everyone has
been saying all along you know that if
he just got on they could have both been
saved blah blah blah now I have a hot
tape okay because I've like read about
the Titanic and that time and the people
who were on the boat and the sacrifices
that were made and I think still if it
were real Jack would not have gotten on
the door right because there would have
been a risk that it could have flopped
like it's hard to get onto it yeah just
like you could knock off the other
person he could have put Rose in a a
scary situation also if the door is like
they just fit then he could have been
looking at it and being like maybe we
won't fit and the men of the Titanic
most of them were like so chivalrous so
many men gave their lives for women and
children and they just stayed on the
boat and they died knowing that they
were gonna die and they said their wives
should go the kids should go like they
so there weren't a lot there were some
men who didn't do that and some who were
selfish and like you know like we saw in
the movie The guy
um but a lot of men like gave their
lives for the women and I think that
Jack Dawson was that man I don't
disagree with that time and would not
have jeopardizes jeopardized Rose's
survival for his own and he could have
just held on he'd have to get on it
because he's in the freezing water yeah
but like hold on for as long as he could
no but like he still would have died as
quickly as if he didn't hold on oh from
like hypothermia yes it wasn't the
drowning it was the weather no it wasn't
the giant thing he's wearing a life
jacket it's the coldness of the water so
if he got on the door he wouldn't be in
the water got it got it but like that's
a balancing act and I don't think he was
going to jeopardize his words you know I
agree it's like a seesaw it's very it's
unbalanced yeah so I think it was it was
about chivalry I I think so too which
like I think a lot of the theme from the
Titanic and the way it went down quite
literally is how chivalrous the men of
that time yeah totally like if something
happened today would it be Women and
Children First I don't think so no I
don't think so I'm not sure I don't
think it would be but of course today
we're like Jack get on the door yeah
right right no I I actually agree I
agree I don't think that's a hot take
okay no it's just like my take you said
you literally before we started the show
I've the hottest take account I didn't
say the hottest you've gotta have a hot
take you literally
my my so my take was that Jack you even
knowing if he maybe could have fit on
the door would not have gotten on that's
not a hot take
like the way you explained it you're
right thank you James Cameron should
call me because like I he thinks he has
a plot hole in his movie but he doesn't
James Cameron should do a lot of things
and one of them should be to call me
yeah what else should he do you know
cast me in his next film when he calls
me I could tell yeah I guess everything
I need from him he could do on the call
yeah because he should definitely make
like a bio pick about the toast and like
this you know unprecedented success
and the thousandth episode should be
directed by James Cameron what do you
think he would do with us something like
he'd probably like move the camera
around something breathtaking
yeah I guess I don't know if he could
handle us because we you don't know when
the next moment is coming in who it's
coming from so I think you would be
excited by the spontaneity of it all you
would have to study a lot of toast
episodes to be in the Rhythm with us
yeah but our rhythm is constantly
shifting no it's like our old episodes
like ew I don't know but maybe through
those episodes he could see the
um the pattern of our growth and we
could predict where we're going next
right he would probably need like a team
of scientists
like and and psychological like
evaluators but honestly I think we break
the mold no that's what I'm saying like
we really are Beyond unpredictable
Beyond like maybe yes if you study
today's episode and like this week he
could guess Thursdays but again just
depends like how we wake up you know
yeah and maybe not Thursdays because
Thursday we intend to do something
special indifference anything before
yeah no it's tough it's definitely tough
yeah but he should still call us
he should and because your movie is
historically accurate yeah how about
that how about them apples if anybody
James's niece listens to the show please
let him know yeah he doesn't even need
to call me just let him know it's
historically accurate No I could still
use a phone call like I definitely I
could use a James Cameron film like to
make my Millions so then I could maybe
rent Kevin Costner's house yeah that's
all we want yeah like we're simple girls
um before we keep coming let me just let
you know that today's episode is also
brought to you by Thrive Cosmetics high
performance episode high performance
Beauty and you're wearing five Cosmetics
on your lips right now oh I am the tip
of the tongue the teeth the lips so
their high performance Beauty and skin
care products are made with Clean Skin
loving ingredients no parabens sulfates
flath lights they're certified 100 vegan
and cruelty free so some of their
best-selling products the ones that
everyone knows is probably the liquid
lash extensions mascara it's the first
vegan tubing mascara it's their best
selling product it has a proprietary
tubing formula that dramatically
lengthens each lash from root to tip I
saw videos of it going viral and I was
like there there's no way and then I
bought it and it really is that [__]
like it's a it's a really amazing
formula it lasts all day without
clumping smudging or flaking and the
removal is super easy it slides right
off with warm water and a washcloth
um this is what I'm wearing today the
sheer strength hydrating lip tint it
deeply hydrates lips with a hint of tint
that applies and evenly lasts every six
hours so it Glides on smoothly for an
even color that's comfortable okay my
shade today is Cara k-a-r-a it's really
nice it's got like the the hydration of
like a bomb but with colors of a bomb a
bomb
um they also have their brilliant eye
brightener which is a really beautiful
shimmery yeah that's the one that will
just make you look awake a highlighting
stick they've got their waterproof
eyeliner we have all the products and
they're part of my collection down here
and at home it's a great time to try
Thrive Cosmetics because they also have
a mission that resonates with us it's
their bigger than Beauty initiative so
every product purchase they donate to
help communities Thrive right now you
can get 15 off your first order when you
visit thrivecosmetics.com toast that's
Thrive
c-a-u-s-e-m-e-t-i-c-s.com slash toast
for 15 off your order today's episode is
also brought to you by stamps.com 2023
is already well underway so don't wait
any longer to level up your business and
set your year up for Success get ahead
of the competition by using stamps.com
to mail and ship they let you print your
own Postage and shipping labels right
from your home or office it's ready to
go in minutes you can get back to
running your business sooner so whether
you have like an e-commerce business or
you have a business that involves a lot
of shipping or you just have like a lot
of shipping needs in your personal life
stamps.com is your One Stop Shop because
taking trips to the post office is
genuinely like as close as it gets to
Hell on Earth
um but stamps.com is the post office
elevated postage rates just increased
again but luckily stamps.com has the
best discounts in the industry with
rates you literally cannot find anywhere
else like up to 84 off USPS and UPS plus
stamps.com automatically tells you your
cheapest and fastest shipping option for
25 years they have been an indispensable
resource for over a million businesses
you get access to USPS and UPS shipping
services that you need to run your
business right from your computer day or
night no traffic no lines no waiting if
you sell products online stamps.com
seamlessly connects with every major
Marketplace and shopping cart use
stamps.com to print postage whether you
wherever you do business all you need is
a computer and a printer and they'll
even send you a free scale so you have
everything you need to get started if
you need a package pickup you can easily
schedule it through your stamps.com
dashboard and you never have to leave
your house which is
kind of everything it's kind of what
life's all about so sign up with promo
code toast for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a free digital scale there's
no long-term commitments or contracts
required you can set your business up
for Success when you get started with
stamps.com today stamps.com Click the
microphone at the top of the home page
and enter code toast at stamps.com that
promo code is toast
thank you turd you're welcome next story
a little behind the scenes Grammys more
Grammys drama behind the scenes Harry
Styles is stage rotated in the wrong
direction during the Grammys backup
dancers recall the choreographic turmoil
before Harry Styles took home the
coveted Grammy problem of the year on
Sunday night he took the stage along
sanity and backup dancers to perform his
chart topping as it was the dance number
saw Styles and the dancers deliver a lot
deliver elaborate moves atop a revolving
turntable I wouldn't say they were
elaborate because they were pretty much
like walking which is not that elaborate
also like the typical like the dance
yeah like but not elaborate
um by any means no on Monday a couple of
those dancers took to social media to
address negative reactions to the
performance revealing that the stage
rotated in the opposite direction than
in their rehearsals the choreographer
said 12 of us were on the turntable and
we rehearsed for 10 days getting down
these beautiful formations and sliding
off the turntable and Harry did such a
good job integrating into it and had a
beautiful duet we were practicing with
the turn table counterclockwise and we
did it loads of times and got it down to
the point wearing dress rehearsal
yesterday it was spotless unfortunately
when it was time to showcase the number
on live TV the turntable started
spinning the wrong way
that would explain why it was a little
not amazing no and Harry like also fell
off yeah assembled yeah and he was going
down
um
yeah so I I mean I thought the
performance itself was fine in terms of
the choreography I never would have
noticed that something was wrong I
really felt like something was off with
Harry maybe I threw him though for sure
um but I felt like he carried that same
kind of morose like somber energy with
him throughout the night yeah so it
didn't feel connected to the turntable
and I feel like Harry's such a
professional like he he's not easily
thrown you know he's done the biggest
stages in the world yeah so I don't know
if that had anything to do with his
energy but that sucks for the dancers
who like you know this is their moment
yeah I just feel like I mean you never
know what you're gonna do in a situation
where you have to think on the spot but
I feel like if I were Harry like I would
have come down from the turntable when
it was the time like when he stumbled
and it would have stayed at the
microphone [__] the turntable [__] the
turntable because then also even though
the dancers wouldn't know what to do
with themselves the camera light is on
you yeah no and he's such a great
performer if he just dances and does his
thing like he doesn't need the fruit the
turntable would have been it's an homage
to the music video so it's like okay it
was in the beginning hey it's the music
video and if he stayed at the mic the
whole time I wouldn't have noticed
anything and I also feel like I didn't
think the performance was that bad
especially like the turntable stuff
um it was more so Harry's energy but now
knowing that it went the wrong way I'm
like oh it was a total [__]
clusterfuff yeah yeah it could have been
way worse I feel like if I were Harry I
kind of wouldn't want people to know
that it went the wrong way because now
like his appointment his whole like uh
performance is like kind of a failure
right right as opposed to it just being
like oh it was like nothing about his
best yeah but now I'm like oh everything
went wrong yeah that's true so I think
I'd be like a little like miffed at all
these backup dancers spilling the tea I
feel like they had approval you think I
don't think I think backup dancers are
like extremely professional they're
always around like really A-list
celebrities they don't just like speak
out especially when Harry is you know
such a big artist and has so many
performances like you want to be a part
of his crew for like he has a long
career ahead of him and I feel like
backup dancers like stick with you like
Taylor's dancers yeah with her forever
so they're not gonna be acting out like
speaking at a turn I don't think they
like think they're doing anything wrong
I think they get approval like a hundred
percent you think so yeah they know the
second like all the major major Harry
fans follow them they know the second
they say anything it gets picked up I
think without a doubt they had his
approval
I don't know because it's also like you
know people thought I didn't do a great
job I want them to know what was really
going on like there wasn't there was a
reason I don't know if you even think to
get approval for like just you know
sharing your truth on Tick Tock you do
when you work for like the biggest and
the baddest when and it comes to social
media you have to get approved I'm I'm
sure of it
okay and I could see them wanting it out
there like well you know the discourse
is Harry stunk it up well let's tell
them why yeah but I think at least for
me and my perception of it like it it
just makes me think the performance was
worse than it than it was yeah
also like there's a video of like Harry
and Taylor talking do you see this and
the tick tocker like her Theory which I
do believe this one is that Harry is
telling Taylor that the stage was going
the wrong way because he like goes like
this and then she's like oh
yeah yeah I'm gonna love it so like
unlike diplos yeah I believe that I'm
loving the lip reading yeah people you
know who are either like deaf or just
experts in lip reading or sharing on
social media like what they think they
see and because I'm not a good lip
reader but then when I see like somebody
say I'm like oh yeah that's it but it's
but it could not be it it's subjective
for sure you know so take it with a
grain of salt though I believe this one
because it's like okay he went like that
and also it's not a harmful thing
whereas like Satan Diplo said that they
bought that it's like not nice for
everyone no and also like you you have
to be dumb to do that because when you
walk into the Grammys and you're sitted
at you know seated at a certain like a
handful of tables you know like your
reactions are gonna be on TV you may not
see the camera but you know that you
could be on TV especially when they're
doing your category so you wouldn't say
something that's stupid no I don't
believe it yeah I still don't
are you ready for our fifth and final
story which is some wonderful human
interest news and that we need to be
highlighting wonderful stories like this
of exceptional people is it some good
news good asked news it's good news to
you it's good news
a nine-year-old boy who wants to be an
astrophysicist graduates from high
school nine years old While most
nine-year-olds are eagerly anticipating
graduating from elementary school this
Pennsylvania boy just got his high
school diploma David balagun 9 recently
received a diploma from reach Cyber
Charter School which is based in
Harrisburg after taking online classes
this achievement makes David one of the
youngest people to graduate from high
school he started High School right
before covid-19 closed doors to schools
in early 2020 and he continued his
studies virtually ever since per the
upper um The Guardian he ended up
graduating in three years with a 4.0 GPA
the science teacher said David was an
inspirational kid definitely one who
changes the way you think about teaching
you always hear about that the teachers
have like their one kid they're like
that makes all these other kids let me
see a picture of this kid is he so so
cute look at him sitting on his computer
with his headphones oh my God he's
adorable he literally looks four years
old he's so young and now he's going to
college he wants to go astrophysics
assist
um does that mean an astronaut he's
already started getting his credits at
Bucks County Community College oh my God
he's that's where Brian's from Bucks
County yeah so I hope um they're still
considering the family told uh the
outlet they're still considering ivy
league institutions such as Harvard
Princeton and UPenn I think probably now
with all this media like you still have
to snatch him up there'll be a spot for
him um but I look forward to seeing the
incredible things that he does oh my God
he's adorable I'm so happy for him like
one thing about me like that could never
have been me like I was really not smart
like in school it was like a definitely
a lack of passion yeah like a lack of
giving a shred of a [__] but also a lack
of the talent like I was just not smart
so I feel like you know maybe in my life
I look back like I could have become
like definitely some sort of like
singing Prodigy maybe even if I'd
applied myself a little bit like at the
piano or the guitar like maybe I could
have been I could not have been an
academic Prodigy like I know never never
I mean really few people can be you have
to be like incredibly smart because you
could be like really really smart and be
number one in your class to graduate
high school at nine years old like you
have to be motivated too and like
there were a lot of kids I knew growing
up who were like naturally smart like
they didn't have to study that I'm
actually just like it worked for them
but they never like it's like you have
to have that but then you also have want
to have like apply yourself like it's
hard to have both yeah and so he said he
wants to be an astrophysicist and he
wants to study black holes and
supernovas like I'm sorry if he's not on
the next flight to space Oh yeah
somebody snatch them up Elon the next
civilian flight to space What are you
doing so true Elon or Jeff or Richard
anyone Richie they're taking off every
day no totally with like the dumbest
most irrelevant groups yeah like this
kid I wonder if there if you have to be
a certain age to go to space like maybe
yeah can't handle space for sure by the
way yeah I love that story thank you is
that a beautiful story about the campers
doing incredible things and we need to
highlight we do stories because these
are good stories and more people should
you know strive for excellence yes
academic excellent all forms of
Excellence you know this kid is not just
like sitting around on Tick Tock you
know he's not on Tick Tock this kid is
our best bet at beating China your best
bet I hope yeah I hope he has a lot of
friends who he encourages you know a lot
of Youth it must be hard to find peers
who are worthy of your time especially
when like your time is so valuable
you're literally graduating college and
the time the kids are going to soccer
practice literally but also always
making time for fun for fun hobbies but
I feel like he is and I feel like his
hobby his hobbies are like space
exploration yeah physics and so it's so
important to get out there you know run
around with other kids yeah I hope he's
you know playing Kobe gets outside you
know he's not just on the computer all
day I know like with his headphones like
a telemarketer like yeah talking to
people online yeah he's got to like see
other kids I agree with that yeah maybe
now that he's had this major
accomplishment maybe he'll take like a
few months off and like go to camp or
something not him never Camp he's
already working on his college credits
and by the way it's winter camp okay you
go to space camp yeah but also science
camp and then he's gonna be on a college
campus and like he's gonna be the only
nine-year-old like that's got to be
isolating no I hope that you know I hope
his family kids are nice to him I hope
his family moves with him yeah he needs
all the support he can get I'm not kind
of worried about him now right college
campuses are tough even when you're of
age but he's Purpose Driven right he's
not really worried about like the social
elements of it all he's there for a
purpose he'll probably graduate faster
than I have those other snot nose kids
and if you wind up at a college that he
is and he's in your lecture like you
better be [__] nice to him invite him
to like have lunch with you yeah all you
know age-appropriate don't get him
hooked on alcohol or drugs please I
could see it going that way too like a
young impressionable kid these college
kids are crazy they like invite him to
the frat house right like they think
it's funny like and then he does a
headstand the next thing you know he's
living on the street like no no like we
have to protect him I hope his parents
like are really involved they have to
they have to be they have to be so
exciting so excited like Goodwill
Hunting but like even better yeah nine
years old
wishing him the best at his academic
Endeavors I look forward to seeing what
he does remember that name I look
forward to seeing big things from him
yeah
um and speaking of big it's time for
lunch so what are we thinking I think
it's more like what aren't we thinking
like I'm feeling adventurous I'm feeling
big are you feeling like we're gonna go
leave the house we're gonna leave the
house okay because I think when we sit
in the house and wait for lunch to find
us it's so we always just end up eating
some crap yeah we do you want to tell me
about a place that's nearby that has
good bowls oh yeah let's go get bowls
yeah when they like I feel like like
this trend of like this Lunch Spot trend
for like corporate life like I feel like
forever it's been like good salad places
it was like sweet green and chopped like
all these salad and now the bowl
industry is making its come back like
warm rice warm like a warm protein yeah
grilled chicken or something it's cooked
like I like the bowl I was thinking like
when I was reading lessons in chemistry
which you read it's like I feel like you
know in the 50s 60s like they put
everything into a casserole thermos like
into a casserole and like now you just
put all these ingredients you
deconstruct them in a bowl yeah but
we're eating the same thing we're eating
a decontracted casserole except for
probably like less cream yeah and also
casseroles are [__] disgusting I
really like the idea of them but I've
never seen one that I wanted to try yeah
but I've seen plenty of bowls I've
wanted except everyone says the lasagna
is a casserole yes it is it's not no no
sure like it's a casserole sure that's
not what I'm talking about okay how
about that I would love lasagna we can
make lasagna for dinner yeah
okay let me think about so I hope you
guys have some great lunch plans we just
sounds like we got a good one yeah we
have a good one I hope we've inspired
you
um you know you could get a wrap you
could get a salad
maybe you brought lunch from home which
is literally the best kind of lunch yeah
because you know it was made with love
yeah I think people have some of that
Annie's mac and cheese in the fridge for
for the uh for for Harry like maybe just
like to hold me over yeah you could have
some of that it's like I'm really hungry
no I'm like a bottomless pit all right
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the millennial morning show
this was our 998th episode
hope you guys have an amazing day thank
you so much
investors every Monday Friday news for
watching this on YouTube please
subscribe give this video thumbs up also
available
very very special places
[Music]